in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Adam
and Michelle are with us from Evansville
Indiana welcome guys how are you doing
great good to have you guys
so you're here to do a debt-free scream
yes good to have you thanks for coming
down from Evansville how much have you
paid off
I paid off sixteen thousand six hundred
dollars in 17 months as a single mom
excellent okay but you're standing here
with Adam so tell me this story I met
Adam November year 14 mm-hmm
2014 he actually introduced me to your
principles and paid for us to go to an
FPU class together and from there I
started my debt snowball and I promised
him I'd have it paid off before the
wedding and I accomplished it three days
beforehand oh wow very cool and so how
long have you guys been married about a
month yeah well congratulations
and so really Michele this is your story
with Adam being a cheerleader exactly
okay very cool and so what were you
making during the 17 months with my
bonuses about 39,000 good gosh did you
sell something nothing really big I sold
our riding lawnmower we only brought in
about 500 okay and so you did this by
budgeting on beans and rice yeah and
really cut back on stuff and just
through every dime of every extra to it
man oh man so you said you're a single
mom how many kids have you got weight
and how old she's five awesome very cool
and what's her name Abigail okay good so
17,000 in 17 months making 39,000 as a
single mom three days before the wedding
ding ding rings the bell but you went
through as part of your engagement
process went through Financial Peace
University together yes okay
Wow so Adam tell me how I mean you have
to be standing back going yeah I got a
good one I did Dave you're absolutely
correct
this is incredible it is it's an amazing
accomplishment
very proud cheerleader in my corner I'm
sorry I had a heck of a cheerleader in
my corner yeah I guess so so were you
looking at the budget together all the
time and he's just shown you I'm working
with you and cheering you on and when
you're tired saying you can do it and
all that huh yeah we did monthly budget
meetings together where we compared each
other's spreadsheets and figured out
exactly where we were going and I'd send
him a little text messages hey I'm gonna
have extra $200 this month yay this is
great very cool very cool so how long
did you all date before you were engaged
dated six months before we were engaged
and it was another six months to the
wedding okay all right so during this
time Wow very good this is great very
well done
so as a single mom doing this stuff
Michelle at the time talked to the
single moms that are out there and tell
him how you did this it's hard there's a
lot of saying no there's a lot of times
that you're walking through you know the
checkouts and you know it's I want a
candy bar and it's no honey I'm sorry
not today we're out of pocket money this
month or you know it's cutting way back
for like Christmas and birthdays and
stuff too to get it all completed in the
long run you know she's not going to
notice the extra for presents missing
under the tree but she's going to be
able to notice that I'll be able to help
her out with college now yeah and the
two of you have started a marriage off
with what an incredible story I mean to
be able to combine this story and and
you know to walk together but not
together kind of thing and then but but
to be able to bring this into the first
month of your marriage this is awesome
it is very very cool so what do you say
the key is that the big thing is saying
no that's it that's a lot of it I mean
when I really looked at my budget I
spent a lot of little extra dollars you
know on things that you know would bring
an immediate smile to her face when we
were in the store but in the long run
aren't that important you you don't
think a five dollar book is very much
but if you go to the store twice a week
and you buy a five dollar book each time
that that's a pretty quickly during the
course of the month
yeah and over the course of a year it's
a lot yeah yeah that's very true
interesting very cool so Adam what is
your suggestion if somebody's out there
listening and they're cheerleading's
somebody on like you were what do you
what did you how did you look at this
process
just the stay very positive and being a
constant encourage or avoid negative
comments that's probably not the worst
thing you can do that's the last thing
she needs to hear as she goes through
the process so a constant like role
model and cheerleader mm-hmm so where
were you on the baby steps in this time
frame I was on like the baby step four
or five six seven process yes so you're
paying off a house and saving for
retirement and yes it's college and that
kind of thing yes okay very cool
good very good Wow this is impressive
this is very impressive Michelle very
this math is tough that's tough yeah
yeah tied a tight 17 months yeah it's
not just a year it's it's a year and a
half it's a long time well very very
cool what was the hardest part for you
when we first started the process
I had $3,000 sitting in my savings
account and Adam kept saying you need to
drop that down to a thousand and pay
2,000 towards that you need to do that
and I fought him on that for almost two
months okay
what made you finally do it I realized
that you know he was right once I got
the debt paid off I'd be able to build
up you know an emergency fund to where I
was comfortable again and we just had to
have a lot of faith that nothing major
was gonna happen during that timeframe
but a thousand would be enough to cover
any sort of little minor inconvenience
that could come up yeah absolutely
very cool well you guys are impressive
this is a great story it's a different
story I like it it's a very good story
though very great ending for sure for
sure very well done
how does it feel now that you're there
when you put when you're real now when
you hit that last thing three days
before the wedding you had to be doing a
Snoopy dance oh yeah you had to be going
nah I think the text message had like
400 exclamation points behind it I would
show that that's excellent good all
right Adam but really Michelle and
Abigail from Evansville Indiana $17,000
paid off in 17 months making 39 thousand
a year count it down
let's hear your debt-free scream ready
yes one to you sir we're debt-free job
you guys that is awesome
man that works so beautiful
very well done love it love it love it
that is excellent well done hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show you are
not a victim you're not a victim of big
corporations you're not a victim of Wall
Street you're not a victim of capitalism
you're not a victim of wealth inequality
you're not a victim of racism you're not
a victim